oh it's the ultimate showdown
German that's the UK and you've got a
vegan KitKat which I know I've had one
of these they are pretty close and then
they're wild and this though there's a
mass of this
that's great let's start with the camera
reopening it are you opening it like
that now do you know what annoy if my
friend's watching this I want to do
something that I know will annoy him
how annoying is that
you can't do that it's the most I hate
doing it but I know that he hates seeing
it more all right I mean that's so good
but it you know it's a KitKat I don't
want to lose my mind over just a kick up
crunchy whole hazelnuts
[Music]
yeah really yep
I love like big nuts in my chocolate
foreign